it's the last show of the year and we're
looking at some of the biggest stories
of the year and what bigger story as we
got towards the end of this year then
the 2016 presidential race we're going
to look at three clips that really
represent some of the biggest storylines
of the 2016 election so far on the one
hand Bernie Sanders and we will see
Bernie Sanders at Liberty University
where he slayed the crowd and it really
was proof that the ideas of Bernie
Sanders portrayed by so many as these
extreme left ideas actually resonate
with Americans from the entire political
spectrum and then we will look at a clip
about Donald Trump and a clip about ben
Carson two clips that I believe really
tell us the most important things about
Donald Trump and Ben Carson which is
that they didn't really don't know a lot
of stuff and they wouldn't make good
president although we hope they will
stay in the Republican primary race as
long as possible so reviewing some of
the biggest storylines of 2015 Bernie
Sanders no question one of those biggest
storylines as well as Donald Trump and
Ben Carson take a look one of the most
interesting individual little stories
from these early days of the 2016
presidential campaign happened yesterday
Democratic presidential candidate Bernie
Sanders spoke at the private Christian
college Liberty University this is the
traditionally far-right religious school
it's in Lynchburg Virginia it was
founded by the extremists televangelist
and pastor Jerry Falwell this is a
perfect speaking gig for candidates like
Rick Santorum or Ben Carson for Ted Cruz
remember everybody all the student body
being forced to go to the mandatory
rally for Ted Cruz not really a great
fit for the more moderate Republicans
and really not a good fit you would
think for one of the most progressive
candidates in a long time Bernie Sanders
but Bernie Sanders spoke there yesterday
he was asked a question about protecting
unborn children and the entire exchange
is absolutely endlessly fascinating
Louis the question was about protecting
the unborn two things to pay attention
to number one pay attention
do the raucous standing ovation and
applause for the anti-abortion
anti-choice language that was used by
David Nasser the house pastor whatever
he's called at Liberty University in
framing the question but then
interestingly pay attention to the
reaction to Bernie Sanders is a answer
to the question let's look senator
senator Sanders you've talked in your
campaign about how it is immoral to
protect the billionaire class at the
expense of our most vulnerable in
society obviously children you just
mentioned that even in your talk with us
earlier a majority of Christians would
agree with you but what but here's the
question a majority of Christians would
agree with you but would also go further
and say that children in the womb need
our protection even
how do you reconcile
so the question sir is obviously there
you can see this is what they want to
ask Rollo this is what's honor how do
you reconcile the two and again I know
that you have a different view I know
that a user and I don't have to be eye
to eye on it but I sense a real
sincerity in you in wanting to see our
children protected you can you see Sir
how we see the child in the womb as the
most vulnerable that needs protection I
doing this yes but I do also understand
understand this is an area where we
disagree I do understand and I do
believe that it is improper for the
United States government or state
government to tell every woman in this
country the very painful and difficult
choice that she has to make on that
issue and I honestly don't want to be
too provocative here but very often
conservatives say you don't get the
government out of my life I don't want
the government telling me what to do but
on this very sensitive issue of which
this nation is divided a lot of people
agree with you a lot of people agree
with me but my view is I respect
absolutely a family that says no we are
not going to have an abortion I
understand that I respect that but I
would hope that other people respect the
very painful and difficult choice that
many women feel they have to make and
don't want the government telling them
what they have to do
this clip really shows me what is
refreshing about Bernie Sanders there's
nothing that feels crafted or concocted
about his answer it's just his honest
honest view it should and does appeal to
at least some people on both sides and
there was more applause than I would
have anticipated for Bernie Sanders
speaking at Liberty University there was
he he wasn't afraid to say that hey we
differ on this issue uh and I wonder how
many people were actually enlightened
when he started bringing up uh you know
things about the Republican budget and
uh its lack of morality uh but there did
seem to be a fair amount applause of
applause even for that and so uh I you
know I'm hoping that he has a bunch of
supporters in that crap even the
politicians that would be more on the
side of the liberty university crowd
when they're asked questions they sort
of hem and haw and waffle and speak in
generalities and talking points Bernie
Sanders stands by his convictions he
explains why these are his convictions
these are the exact same things he says
in front of liberal audiences and he got
some cheers for it this was not ever
going to be his crowd but he gives the
same message that he gives to a liberal
crowd and it does to some degree
resonate and this is just further
confirmation that the Bernie policies
are not fringe extremist ideas these are
the popular mainstream policies it's
just that they get all wrapped up in in
in names like communism and socialism
and blah blah blah and that is just a
distraction because these are pretty
real reasonable middle of the road ideas
that Bernie Sanders is presented and if
the people need to keep sharing videos
of Bernie Sanders in the Bernie Sanders
mean quotes because that's really how
you get this message across me Dave
imagine if we didn't have social media
right now what would Bernie's name
recognition look like without all of
that yeah I'd be even lower than it that
it currently is and will continue to
track where that goes fascinating
Bernice laying at Liberty University not
a headline we would have been
proof of the fact that I don't think
Donald Trump has any clue what he's
talking about we now go to video of
Donald Trump over the weekend being
interviewed by George Stephanopoulos on
ABC's this week if you don't like
cringing you might wanna tune away from
this next segment Donald Trump has
talked for a while now about his
immigration ideas he's gonna deport the
illegal immigrants he's going to build a
wall blah blah blah George
Stephanopoulos decided to speak very
specifically to Donald Trump about how
we would do that let's discuss the costs
let's discuss how it would be done and
Donald Trump imploded completely fell
apart it became abundantly clear he has
no idea what he's talking about let's
take a look at this video brace
yourselves get the children out of the
room because this is absolutely
cringe-worthy take a look look at this
from the American action forum
conservative group they say the federal
government would have to spend roughly
400 to 600 billion dollars to address
the oven 11.2 million undocumented
immigrants each immigrant would have to
be apprehended detained legally
processed transported his or her own
country in turn this would shrink the
labor force by 11 million workers
reduced real gdp by one point six
trillion dollars are you willing to pay
that price and where you gonna get the
money well first of all they're wrong
and you know Jeb is a very low-energy
person he'd never be able to do it he's
the one that said they'd come out of an
act of love okay this is an act of love
these are people coming and many of them
you look at what's happening with the
crime many of them are really causing
tremendous problems and they would be
out really fast immediately first day we
start that movement but we need a wall
we have to get a wall we need great
purity and we're gonna have a ball that
would be not let people in George headed
by the way legally if your legal you can
come in and we'll let you see there let
me press you on the cost right there mr.
Trump they're saying four hundred six
hundred billion dollars it would require
big government apparatus to take
everybody down if you don't think those
numbers right how much is it going to
cost and where you're going to get the
money well it's costing us a hundred and
thirty billion dollars a year and that's
peanuts compared to what the real cost
is yours for the way we have it now you
have
many illegals we don't even know how
many illegals I hear 11 million I hear
30 million the government has no idea we
have lost control of our country we've
lost control of our borders the
government has no idea how many illegals
there I've been hearing 11 videos for
five years then the other day I heard 30
nobody has any of those there's no idea
how are you going to round them all up
where are you going to get the money
where are you going to get the forces
exactly how are you going to do it what
are the specific called management the
first thing we have to do is secure the
border but it's called management and
we'll get people back in the really good
ones we're going to expedite it so they
get back in so they can at least come in
Legally but we have tutoring hiders one
idea to yonce hell if she's major you
declare how you're going to do it but
you don't say how George I'm telling you
it's called management you can do this
and we can expedite the good ones to
come back in and everybody wants that
but they have to come in Legally we have
a country we have to have our country of
laws were country of borders how can you
have a country without a border that's
right Louis Donald Trump would do it
through management well I'm convinced
that sounds like a pretty logical
strategy to me management he is doing
what many politicians are guilty of and
that's making promises and saying you're
gonna do things with no explanation as
to how and usually things that are very
expensive but can he can he manage his
way through this I don't think so and
you know never mind that the costs
combined with the GDP loss would be
staggering never mind that Donald Trump
claims to be a small government
conservative and what he's suggesting
would be a hugely intrusive large
government apparatus is George
Stephanopoulos accurately points out I
wonder this is the concern I have
because it's it's obvious Donald Trump
knows nothing about immigration will the
Trump fans abandon him when they
realized that he doesn't even understand
his own ideas many of which would
require absurd government spending or
intrusion which conservatives claim to
oppose as well as violations of US law
or trade policy will the Trump
supporters abandon him when they realize
that or are they sticking with them I
don't see
his followers abandoning him I think
it's he's already made it pretty clear
that he doesn't understand these issues
and they're sticking with it how much
worse is gonna get I guess if he wins
the primary and has to debate whoever it
might become more clear but are they
gonna vote for the Democrat after that
now it probably not and if you look at
some of the comments online two video
clips of this exchange and news articles
written about this there are
conservatives who are saying Oh George
Stephanopoulos was being overly
aggressive and sandbagging Trump George
Stephanopoulos just ask the question how
will you do this and then said hey
here's some data about this how will you
do this and Trump had no answer other
than management if your critique is of
George Stephanopoulos you're either
willfully ignorant or just blind to the
reality of that exchange it was like
being angry at Katie Couric for asking
sarah paling what do you read uh and yo
was that sandbagging I I don't think so
was that gotcha journalism oh it's that
was a completely unfair question nobody
knows what they read unless they've been
prepped on what they read by their staff
and that was absolutely gotcha
journalism I was interested to read an
article in The New York Times yesterday
which was posted to our david pakman
show subreddit at david pakman.com slash
reddit which explained that ben Carson
the Republican presidential candidate
has really been having trouble grasping
foreign policy according to his own
advisers he seems to just not get it and
this became much more clear in the last
week ben Carson number one claiming that
China has intervened militarily in Syria
that just didn't happen to me just
flat-out did not happen and two of his
top advisors said in interviews that he
has struggled to master the intricacies
of the Middle East and national security
and that even intense tutoring was
having little effect he is being
intensely tutored and it is having no
impact let's take a look at that a quote
from the new york times article quote
nobody has been able to sit down with
him and have him get one iota of
intelligent information about the Middle
East this is according to Dwyane
Claridge a top adviser to ben Carson on
terrorism and national security claridge
also said that mr. Carson
weekly conference calls to brief him on
foreign policy quote so we can make him
smart and then it really got bad when
ben Carson appeared on Fox News Sunday
with chris wallace i'm calling this ben
Carson Sarah Palin moment i'll remind
you what i mean by that this is when
Sarah Palin was asked by Katie Couric
during the run-up to the two thousand
eight election name a publication that
you read and then this happened and when
it comes to establishing your worldview
I was curious what newspapers and
magazines did you regularly read before
you were tapped for this to stay
informed to understand I wrote most of
them again with a great appreciation for
the press for the media what my mema
cific Lee I'm curiously all of them any
of them that have been in front of me
over all these years i am using i have a
vast variety of sources where we get our
news to alaska isn't a foreign country
where it is kind of suggested it seems
like wow how could you keep in touch
with what the rest of Washington do you
see maybe thinking and doing when you
live up there in Alaska believe me
Alaska is like a microcosm of a mirror
yeah so that was gotcha journalism as we
remember Louis chris wallace very
similarly asking a super simple question
to ben Carson at least it's a question
that should elicit a real answer from a
leading Republican presidential
candidate you say dr. Carson you want to
build a coalition to fight Isis well who
do you build the coalition with in other
words name a country that is a friend of
the United States right if we boil it
down that's the question name a country
that is a friend of the United States
here's how it happened it is just
embarrassing for ben Carson I almost
feel bad for the guy I said controlling
if I may let me just focus on the
military component because obviously
after the slaughter of over a hundred
people while all of those are important
components the military component is the
most immediate one and you have said
that you would as president try to
create an international coalition
militarily to go after Isis how would
you put that together who would you call
first yeah well what I was just
explaining is
you know how we use the resources that
we have you know that that includes some
of our Special Ops people working in
conjunction with an effective fighting
force there those are the kinds of
things that will create enthusiasm as we
begin to take that the land take back
the areas and and damage their image
throughout the world but who would you
call first round perfectly to put
together an international military
coalition my point being that if we get
out there and we really lead and it
appears that we're making progress then
all of the Arab states and even the non
arab states who i think are beginning to
recognize that that the jihad movement
is global it is not just local in the
Middle East but if we fight it there
yeah they will have to pool their
resources in that area and that we won't
have to necessarily fight them here
that's what I'm saying but can you tell
us who you would call purse around three
on the international scene I would call
for all of the Arab states to be
involved in this I would call for all of
our traditional allies to be involved in
this you know I don't want to leave
anybody out because this amazing
available out there so it's the same
Sarah Palin was as what do you read she
said well you know I I read stuff and
and then the the follow-up was we'll
just name something is I read everything
and ben Carson doing the same thing well
who would you call first it's a
non-answer and then it's well i would
call all of the Arab states and all of
the non arab states he would call every
country Louis that's who he would call
the answer here well I mean my easy
answer just say Israel I know I was
thinking to myself you would imagine
that at a minimum you could at least
name some allies we've had right say
well the UK we would talk to the UK and
and maybe maybe France I mean they've
just been there taking action they've
just been attacked and of course you can
always say Israel right say anything to
avoid looking totally clueless what do
you read all of them who would you call
all the Arab and non arab states is this
going to be called a gotcha question is
well I I think it's uh it's a fair
gotcha question right because they know
that he's not up to speed on foreign
policy I but I don't know that that mean
you're you're you're giving the
reporters credit in that they know that
this guy's clueless he presents himself
as a Republican candidate I don't think
it's out it's a gotcha question to say
who would be in in your mind our allies
if you wanted to build a military
coalition just Nate Nate give us a list
of countries name a single country well
I I mean I think I think everyone knows
that foreign policy is not this guy
strong suit that's a sure even advisors
now yeah I first some red meat out there
Republicans love hearing about the
alliance with Israel throw it out there
we will of course continue following
election 2016 starting in 2016 with our
next show we will take our last break
and next we will look at just a
hilarious comment about American foreign
policy that stands out to me is one of
the funniest clips of the year